という まあ大変大胆な問題なんですね
何のために生きてるんですか？という質問
自分で聞く人もいるし
全然それは聞かない人もいるんです
その質問 自分で聞かなくちゃいけないんですね
一体全体 私は何のために生きてるんですかと
その質問を自分に聞く人もいるし
別に自分に聞かない人もいるんですね
自分に聞いたって聞かなくたっても
それは別に問題ないんだけど
聞かない人々の中で 一部の人々があまりにも忙しいんです
生きることで 朝から晩までもう必死になってやらなくちゃいけないことはいっぱいあります
で 仕事をしなくちゃいけないし
他のいろんなことをやらなくちゃいけないし
あまりにも忙しくて まあ自分が生きてるかという実感もなくて
ただ忙しいだけに追われて生活しているんですね
ですから まあそんなもうことを考える暇がないんです
余裕がないんですね そういう人々がまあ一応いるんですね
もう一部は まあ全然鋭くなくて
まあ言われる通りに生きてるんだと
で 言われる通りにやって
まあそれなりになんとか何とかして
それでまあ生活してるだけで
一応生きることにまあおごれているような感じで
まあ仕事あればいいんじゃないかと
家族がいればそれでいいんじゃないかと
まあ美味しいご飯を食べればそれでいいんじゃないかと
夜よく眠れ 眠れ 眠れるならば
それで幸せだと で 病気とかなんとかないならば
それでよかったと思って
まあそれだけで生活してるんですね
それは我々から見れば
あんまり鈍くてね シャープじゃないんですね
ですから 忙しくて そんな余裕がない人にはちょっと何も言えませんだけど
もうただシャープじゃなくて
まあ食べて寝て もう仕事をして生きて死ぬまで生きてると
それで満足してるという人々
そんなにシャープじゃないんですね
そこで自分について じゃあ何のために生きているかと
その質問を考える人々もまた 2つに分けられますね
そこで悪い方法なんですけど
まあいろんなことをやってはみるんだけど
失敗する うまくいかない
失望する それで一体何のために生きてるんですか？という問題
自分に聞くんですね で
失望する あるいは生きる勇気がない
なんとかにチャレンジする勇気がない
精神的に弱い それで弱みがあると同時に
やっぱり負けるのも怖いし
だからって何かにチャレンジするのもまた怖いし
そういうふうなことで
逃げ道として 何のためにそんなことをやらなくちゃいけないんですかと
何のために我々はそんなに必死になって生きていかなくちゃいけないんですか？とは言うんだけど
問題は考えますけど 結局あれは本気ではなくて
一つの逃げ道として 自分の弱みを隠す方法として考えている人々もいるんです
でもう一つの人々っていうのは
別にチャレンジしたくないということでもなくて
負けるのは怖いということでもなくて
やっぱり考えてみるので
人間一体何やってるんですかと
私たちは生きていてから
まあずっと死ぬまで もう結局何やってるんですかと
そんなに何か大事な意味があるんですかと
まあシャープな気持ちがありまして
シャープな心がありまして
考えてみる それで私は道を 4種類に分けてしまったんですね
何のために生きているかと疑問
自問する人としない人を 2つに分けて
その中でも 2種類  2種類分けたんです
その中でやっぱり 2つがあまりもう関係ないんですね
まあただもうシャープじゃなくて鈍感で
問題は見落としないということだけで
まあそれからまあ一応時間の関係もありますから
できるだけ早く いろいろことを言いますけど
その同じ問題はね やっぱり何のために生きているんですかということね
お釈迦様も考えてみたんですね
で 考えてみたところで
やっぱり解決法を見つかりましょうということで
まあすごい勇気を持って社会から出て
人生ってどういうものかということは徹底的に観察してみたんですね
いろんな研究をしてみたんですね
人間のいろんな目的がありまして
その目的についてよく実験したりはしました
一番わかりやすい目的っていうのは
まあ楽しければいいんじゃないかと
とにかく そういうことで
もう楽しみを追っていく人生
で それは世の中で まあほとんどの人々はそういう楽しみを追っていくんですね
楽しみを追っていくんだけど
またそちら辺であまりはっきりしないんですね
何が楽しみかと で お釈迦様は世の中
自分のことを見たら これはまあ
目でいろんなものを見て楽しむ
耳でいろんなことを聞いて楽しむ
口で 舌で楽しむ 鼻で楽しむ
体で楽しむと それからいろんなことを考えたりして
まあ本を読んだり いろいろ物事を考えたりして楽しがったりする
それだけのことは楽しみではないかと
でも人間はそれはわからなくて
理解しないで ただ外の世界のことをずっと追っていくんですね
で そこでまあ何か何のために生きているか分からなくなっちゃうんですね
いわゆる どういうことでしょうか
で 例えば金儲かると いきなりもう金儲からなくちゃいけないという概念が頭に入ってしまっちゃうんですね
そこで何のためかということを忘れしまっちゃうんです
忘れしまって とにかく儲かればいいんじゃないかという
そこでもう行ってしまっちゃうんです
それで結局自分の楽しみも失ってしまっちゃうんです
見失うんですね で もう財産増え
増えましょうと で 財産増えることによって自分の暇が消えてしまって
余裕がなくなって 寝る暇もなくなってしまって
家族と一緒にいる時間もなくなってしまって
ただ大変大変な苦しみを味わうだけで
で その方向はみんなやってまして
結局我々は地球まで破壊して汚染してしまってるんですね
で この自然まで破壊して
また逆戻りできないところまで破壊しているんだけど
そういう人々に聞けば
今まであなた方は何やってきたんです？人間には楽を楽しみを作ってあげたんだと
どうだいと 今の世界はね
すごい優れてるでしょうとか威張ったりもするんですね
今の科学の進歩はものすごい
もう何といいますか 目まぐるしい速さで進歩しているのではないかと
医学なんかはすごいもう速さで進歩しているのではないかとか威張ったりしています
だから逆に言えば それで我々何か役に立ってますかと
楽に生きていられますかと
そうじゃないでしょうに
飲む飲む水もなくなっただけでしょう
体にいい食べ物はなくなっただけでしょうに
で それにまあ遺伝電子工学ですか
そんなものを作って 自然にないものを作ったりして食べさせようとしている
我々は豆腐食べてますけど
これは日本の伝統的なもう食べ物やと威張ったりするんだけど
我々アメリカで電子工学的に作ってる豆で作ってるんですね
と 納豆も同じなんです
ですから 結局人間というのはご飯食べるのは楽しいんですけどね
本当に自然でできたもので手を
人間が余計な欲の手を加えなかったものっていうのはものすごく美味しいんです
ですから 我々はもう発展しようではないかということで
それはなくなったんですね
ですから 欲を追っていく世界
この人間っていうのは
この現に接心をによって我々は楽しむんだということを忘れてしまったことによって
もう大変無茶な生き方をしている
それは現代人だけではなくて
お釈迦様の時代でも人間は同じでしたから
全然変わってないんです
それはもう我々現代人にだけ文句を言えるものじゃないんです
昔も同じなんです 昔も大金持ちがいたんです
それで大金持ちの人は朝から晩まで何やっていますかというと
金儲かっているんです
だからもう どういう意味かわからない
これ 例えで言えばわかります
あの夏 真夏は暖房をついてるような感じなんですね
私に暖房あるんだからつけますよと
夏に暖房をつける必要はないでしょうに
で 金があるんだったら
まあ朝から晩までとにかく金儲けなくちゃ
とにかく金儲けなくちゃという
あの考え方は何でしょうかと
それは昔も同じなんです
お釈迦様のある若い人が弟子な
まあものすごいもう二十歳ぐらいで出家した
すごい若い時 それですごい美男でしたし
である王様がこのもう若い人が出家して
もう何も楽も楽しみもなく
もう生活しているんですね
見たらなんとなくもうかわいそうだと思ったんですね
この若者がもう元気で
もう仕事でもして 金儲けて
結婚でもして遊んで生活すればいいんじゃないかと
ですから この彼には特別なもうまあ
あなたは特別な専門用語で質問されたんだけどね
それは今日は言う気持ちはないんですけどね
で で あなたはね もうちょっと楽しめばどうですか？人生は
人生楽しんで それから後でそういう修行とかなんとかやればどうですかと
ということになりましたけどね
で その若者がこう答えるんですね
あなた方やっていることは一番苦しみだと
無意味だと 人にはもう人が何をやっているかとかわかってないんだと
例えば 美味しいご飯を食べたら美味しかったという満足するんじゃなくて
もっと美味しいものはないかと探してるんではないかと
お金がなくて苦労している人は
何か仕事をして金なんか財産儲けたところで
もっと儲からなくちゃと
それで終わりがあるんですかと
王様たち あなた方のことを見てください
質問したの王様ですからね
ある王が小さな国で王になったところで
これで足らんと 隣の国もつかまなくちゃいけないと
隣の国を攻めているんではないかと
隣の国も自分の国に付けてしまったところで
じゃあ隣の国も安きょうではないかと
どれぐらいやればいいんですかと
それを だから喉が渇いている人が塩水を飲むような飲むような感じで
欲にはキリがないんだと
怒りにはキリがないんだと
ただむちゃくちゃ生きてるだけで
あなた方は苦しんでるんだと
バカなことをやってるんだと
だから私は違う道を選んでいるんだと
そういうふうに答えたんですね
ですから そこを昔も同じことで
財産がある人はもっともっとという感じになっちゃうし
王様が隣の国 また次の国
また次の国ということになってしまっちゃうし
現代も全く同じで とにかく強くなろうと
まあまあ 他の国を攻めることはちょっと現代時代ではちょっと難しいんですから
その代わりに他の方面で戦略しようと支配しようとは頑張っているんですね
何のためにかとわかっていないんですね
何かそちらに意味があるんですかと
例えば ある国が世界で一番強い国になりましたと
それで何かいいところはありますかね？それで
経済的に大国になりましたと
何かそれによって何かいいことはありますかね？人間が幸福になるんですかね
そのせっかく目指している楽しむことはありますかね
これ 消えてしまうんですね
楽しめなくなっちゃうんですね
すごく心配しなくちゃいけない
怖くならなくちゃいけない
ビクビクしなくちゃいけない
そういうことで まあ一般の人々
方々の生き方っていうのは
そういうふうに まあ一応なんか無意味で
お釈迦様の言葉で言えば蜃気楼を追っている動物のようなものだと
走るは走るは で 蜃気楼がもっともっと遠くに飛んで見つかりませんと
そちらに水がないんだと
蜃気楼っていうのは 遠く見ると水のように見えるんですね
映って見えるんで 空も
空が下の地面の中に映って見えたら
当然それは湖だと勘違いするんですね
追っていくんだけど そちらにあるのは水ではなくて
ただのものすごい熱い砂漠のみと
で それに反対の道を歩む人々はまた違うことをやっているんですね
じゃあ 現在生きている世界を否定してみましょうと
普通に家族を作って仕事をして
それなりに生きている世界否定しましょうと言って
まあいわゆる皆様知っている言葉で言えば
出家主義を語るんですね
全部捨てましょうと じゃあそれ全部捨てて
やんわり余計なくだらないことをやったんだからといって
人間がそれによって楽しむかというと
またそれもそうじゃないんだと
で そういうわけで いろいろもう宗教というか哲学などのものが出てくるんですね
人間 本当にわからないんだけど
わかってもないし 体験してもないんだけど
わけのわからないことを言っちゃうんですね
いっぱい世の中にあるんです
あれ まあ人間も体はもうどうでもいいんだと
魂のことを考えなさいと
魂は永遠だと そんなことは体験もしていないし
見て見えてもないし わかってもないんだけど
この現世という世界 生きている実際の世界を否定する人々は
まあどうでもいいことを言っちゃうんですね
あるいはもう誰かに もうすべての生命やら現象の世界は誰かに創られたんだから
その人にすがることでよろしいんかと
よろしいんですよと そんな創った人はいるかいないか
誰もわかってない 見てない
聞いたこともない そのようにいろんな哲学が出てくる
迷信的なものはいっぱい出てくる
占いとか そういう神秘の世界を追っていくんですね
そちらに行をやったり
いろんなことをやったりして
もうそれも結局何も得られないで苦しんで終わってしまうということになるんですね
だから世の中 そのまま肯定するんでもなくて
否定するんでもなくて
別な何か道があるかないかと考えなくちゃいけないんですね
ただ ご飯食べる いくらご飯を食べたっても
もうキリがないんだと
終わりがないんだと 満足できないと言ったところで
じゃあ私は断食しますと
それで満足できる？何の満足もそれによってもできませんだから
音楽をいくら聴いたっても
もう納得いきませんだから僕は絶対的にもう聞きませんと
全部カットするんだといったっても
それは答えにはなりません
そういうのは だから何か我々は違う道を見つからなくちゃいけないということなんですね
で それからまあ 我々はどういう違う道を見つからなくちゃいけないかことをちょっと考えてみましょう
まず見えるのは 人間というのは不思議なこと
この心は明確じゃないんですね
物事を考えると しっかりと厳密に考えようとはしないんですね
知識があるんだとかね
科学は発展しているんだといっても
なんかどこかで本当に立派な考え方かと
このすごい有名な人気のある
世界的に知られている
もう偉い人々のことを見ても
なんかガキたちと子供たちと同じじゃないかと
こういう公の場で言ってはいけないんだけど
今みんな支配されていますね
あのビル・ゲイツさんに
たった一人の人間に じゃあそこでその人は人類の中で現れた素晴らしい人ですかね
世界のどんな国でも ビル・ゲイツさんには頭を下げなくちゃいけない状態になっているんです
じゃあ結局やっていることを見たら
もう我々と何の変わりもないんですね
もう他の会社は潰すわ
人のものを盗むわ  あれほど収入はあるのに
もっともうもっと広げて
もっとしっかり儲からなくちゃいけないと
そればっかりやっているんだから
あちこち裁判になってるんですね
それをまあ一応ほんのちょっとの例で言っただけで
別に私は恨み持ってるわけじゃなくて
私に関係ないことですからね
あまりそう真剣に考える必要ないんですけど
まあ一応それをちょっと危険なところもありますからね
あれ 一人の人に 一人の人の会社に世界は全部支配されているということは
そんなにいいことでもないんです
なぜいいことじゃないかというと
人間は信頼できませんだから
ですから そういう人々のことを見たっても
なんか普通にもうそんなに成長していない
精神的にはほとんど子供と似ていると
こうもうそのままなんですね
ですから この人間にないのは
この鋭さ この英語の言葉で言えば
このシャープネス それはないんです
その代わりにあるのは感情ですね
感情で生きているんです
で 私たち仏教で言うのは
この その感情で生きることは無意味でありますと
同じところでぐるぐるぐるぐる回るだけであって
進歩はない で 感情っていうのは論理はない世界ですね
例えば 好きか嫌いかということには論理はない
科学性はない 客観性はないんです
好きだからやっているんだと
もっと現代的な言葉ではフィーリングですか
このフィーリングでいろんなものを発展したり発明したりしていますけど
そちらには進歩も発展もない
ただ同じところで回っているだけ
もともと人のフィーリングというものには
論理性も具体性も科学性も何もないんですね
で 本当に問題のすべてのポイントはそこだけなんです
そこでフィーリングの問題なんですけど
それは我々よくいつでも言っている
この貪瞋痴の生き方 むさぼりと怒りと無知という智慧のない生き方
それは人間の感情なんですね
例えば バラの花が好きな人がいるとすると
その人にあなた論理的に科学的に説明しなさい
なぜあなたはバラの花が好きですか？と
そういうことはないでしょうに
変わって 例えば三角形の中で
何といいますか 角度がありますから
それを全部計算してみれば度ですよというのはちゃんと説明できます
論理的に 科学的にも もうなんとか客観的に説明できます
なんであんたバラの花が好きですか？と
好きであるならばの話なんですけど
それには何の論理性もない
ですから その貪瞋痴の感情自体が大変
我々は考え考え直さなくちゃいけない
大変な問題なんですけど
人類は全然それ考えてないんです
だから別な生き方といっても
これはもう理解しにくいと思います
例えば怒りも同じことで
なんで怒るんですかと
何の論理もそちらにないんです
きちんとした客観的な
具体的な 合理的な理由があるならば
それはなんとかできるんです
そうないんだから もうどうしようもないんですね
ただ怒るだけ ですから
感情っていうのは大変な問題なんです
そういうことから 人間
今我々苦しんでいる問題はすべて出てくるんです
自信がないとか いつでも落ち込むとか
あるいは悲観的であると
あるいは鬱になってしまったと
ストレス溜まってるんだと
ああだこうだといろんなことを言うんですね
大変 今いろんなことで今心配ばっかしで悩みばっかしですよと
いろんな問題あるんだから
もう体の健康もどんどんどんどん崩れていくんだと
そういういろんなことがあって
それに応えてくださいと言うんですね
今ストレスちょっと溜まってるんだけど
それを何とかしてくれませんかと
だからこのあれ 何て言いますか
アイスバーグ 日本語で何て言いますか？アイスバーグ
氷の山 氷山 で 氷山 上ちょっとあるんだから
あれだけ消してくれと
と言っても それだけはまあ何かすればもう消せますけど
やっぱり問題は氷山だから全部下にも潜ってるんですね
だから船は通らないんです
だからほんのちょっと氷山の上のほう
ちょっとした氷の塊見たら
ものすごく気をつけた方がよろしいなのに
そうじゃなくてもうそれだけ消してくれと
ですから このまあ消したっても
問題はそのままで 船は通らないと
そういうことで 例えば落ち込んでいる人は
まあちょっと落ち込みがありますけど
ちょっとなんとかしてくれませんかと
あるいは悲観的な方々は
私はちょっと悲観的なんですけど
なんとかすぐそれ治る方法はないんですかと
その氷山の上の部分だけ
それだけ問題にするんですね
ですから 私たちの心の中にあるこの感情の世界
だから この言葉にあまり引っかからない方がいいんです
なぜならば 感情のせい
感情をなくそうと思ったら
なんとなくそれでいいかという気持ちもあるかもしれませんだけど
この他の言葉は頭に浮かばないだけで
この感情の世界というと同時に
私はこの非合理的な根拠のない生き方のことを意味しているんですね
ただ生きているんだと
みんなやってるんだからやってるんだというふうな
そういう曖昧ないい加減な生き方
みんな青い色の服を着ているんだから
私も青い色にするんだと
そんな不要な生き方でしょ
感情の生き方っていうのは
会社の一緒に仕事する人々の間
その人々のことを嫌いですよと
合わないんですよと なぜ合わないんですかと
どういうわけですかと
きちんとあなたは分析して原因見つかりましたか？それはないでしょうし
ですから答えないんですね
人間に このままだったら
その方がもうちょっと理解していきましょう
こちらのお知らせでも
この正直に素直にとかいう言葉ありましたけどね
私はこの人間 正直に生きていればいいと思ったっても
それは言葉だけ 単なる正直に生きていられますかね
逆に言えば 人間正直に生きていると
それほど危険なことはないんですね
人間の正直さっていうのは
この貪瞋痴の感情で生きていることでしょうに
あなたのことを嫌いだから
私はもう正直ですよと
あなたのこと好きだから
私は正直だから一緒になりましょう
そういう生き方になりかねないでしょうに
自分が結婚していたっても
もう一人の女の人を見たところで
やっぱり可愛いと感じてしまったと
だからその人をうちに連れてくるんだと
そしたら奥さんが怒るでしょうに
じゃああんた怒ったって私は正直もんだから
だから連れてきたんだと
だから このそういうふうに
このちょっとした大雑把ではなくて
この大まかな例で考えると
正直な生き方っていうのはちょっと考え直した方が
いいんじゃないかなと思います
だから この私のこの一つ
この物事を考える方法
それも教えてあげなくちゃいけないんですね
この何か問題があると
その問題はできるだけ極端的に大きくしてみてください
そうすると見えてくるんです
それは科学的なやり方なんです
だから私はちょっと言い過ぎとかね
もうあり得たありえないものまで言っているのではないかと
いろいろあるかもしれませんだけど
それはわざとやっているんです
ほんのちょっとの問題は
ものすごい もうヒマラヤ山脈ぐらい大きくしちゃうんですね
大きくしたら見えるんです
ですから 正直に生きると
ああ それは素晴らしいといきなり思っちゃうでしょうに
言葉に騙されるんですね
正直な生き方 素晴らしい
冗談じゃないんです その人の正直ということは
まあ考えてみましょう
泥棒も正直な生き方でしょうに
殺戮者もそれは正直な生き方でしょうに
やりたいんだからやってるんだと
このいくつか この現代
このなんか裁判とで新聞とか読みましたけどね
ただ単に人を捕まっては殺す
捕まっては殺す で 人ぐらい殺して殺して殺した
これ その人捕まっても裁判になったんですけど
そうですね  できればもっと殺したいんだと言うんですね
その人が ただそれだけ
子供やら女の人やら もう捕まったら殺すと殺してあっちこっち
だから彼が威張ってるんですね
まあも以上でしたけどね
そこまで殺しても全然見つからなかった
バレなかったらどうだいと
私の生き方とそんな感じで
だから その人の感情が人を見たら
あ こいつ安く安くやっつけてみようかな
それだけでしょうに そこでなんとか工夫して
なんとかその人に話しかけて
もうどこかへ連れて行って殺してしまっちゃうんです
で 他の人は全然知らない
行方不明だと イギリスもどこかで人が人を殺して殺して
大きな大屋敷に住んでいた人なんですけど
自分の屋敷で全部植えておくんですね
家の中でももうベースメントでたくさん人をもう埋めて埋めておいて
それで人は消えるわ消えるわ消えるわ
後で見たら まあその人ではないことを見て
まあ見つかって掘ってみたら
まあ出るわ出るわ出るわ
殺された人々いっぱい
ですから そんなにも無責任で非合理的で鋭くない
この鈍い肝心で やっぱり正直に生きることはいいことやとは言ってはいけません
それは仏教の基本なんです
何しゃべろうとも 無条件で喋ってはいけないんです
すごく気をつけて 厳密に
そうでないと人間にはもう自分には何か新しい道っていうのは発見できないんです
で 私はよく見たら いつでもいいんですね
言うことで 例えば頑張りましょうと
全く無意味な言葉なんですね
はい 頑張りますと そういうことにも惹かれて言っちゃいますけど
そう言わないのは 仏教で言ってる別の生き方なんです
しっかりしましょうと
頑張るということは悪いこととは言いにくいんだけど
何に何のために どんな目的で
どこまでという この明確に具体的にしっかりしていないと
あまりにも大雑把 大胆すぎて
もう生きていられなくなっちゃうんですね
いわゆる満足感を得られないんですね
例えば 子供に 若い人に勉強に頑張れ
頑張りなさいと その場合もちゃんと枠組みを決めてあげた方が
ガイドラインを決めてあげた方がやりやすいんです
その人に そこで親であろうか
学校の先生であろうか
あなたはここまで頑張ってくださいと
ガイドラインをつけてあげれば
その人はそこまで頑張ったならば
まあすごい あんたちゃんとやったと
ちゃんと頑張りましたと
本人もいくらか満足感
充実感は得られるでしょうに
例えば 病気の人のお見舞いに行ったら
頑張ってくださいと 何の役にも立ちません
どうやって頑張るんです？看護師さんにぶん殴ったりとか
病院のご飯も美味しくないんだと思って
それを皿ごとに人にぶん殴ったりとかね
もっと美味しいものを持ってこいとか
だから頑張りなさいではなくて
すごい具体的に 明確に
病気になったら 人がまず体のことをお医者さんがちゃんと面倒見てくれる
ですから それは私たちの仕事じゃないんです
ちゃんと薬を飲みなさいと
ちゃんと注射を打ってもらいなさいと
ちゃんと手術してもらいなさい
それ大きなお世話なんですね
それお医者さんの仕事で
そこで何のために家族と友人がいるかというと
その人を元気づけてあげるためなんですね
だから 病気になると当然精神的に落ち込んじゃう
わーやだとかね どうせ気持ちに気持ちいい状態じゃないんだけどね
病気になるっていうことは
それで私たちはもう明るくしなさいよとかね
落ち込むんじゃないよとかね
泣くんじゃないよとかね
そういうなんとかことで
精神的にその人に元気づけてくれくれれば
頑張ってくださいというよりは
何か意味があると思いますけどね
でもそれは一般の鈍い人々には言いにくいです
だからみんな逃げちゃう
頑張ってくださいと 決まり文句いっぱい作って
しきたりやら決まり文句やら腐るほど作って
それはテープレコーダーの感じで言っちゃうんですね
それで正しい生き方ではないんですね
葬式に行ったらこういうこういう言葉だと
結婚式に行ったらこういうこういう言葉だと
お見舞いに行ったらこういうこういう言葉だと
もう全部決まってあって
そちらにある大事な意味がもうどんどんどんどんではなくて
もうとっくに消えているんですね
で 逆に例えばお見舞いに行って
じゃあ頑張ってくださいというのは簡単ですけど
逆に我々は患者さん お見舞いに行ったところで
病気の人が その人はどんな状態かと
しっかりしているかいないかと理解して
その人にどんな言葉をかければいいんですかと
それは考えて発見してしゃべることは難しいんですね
それには知恵が必要なんですね
だから誰ともやろうとしない
それで人間の苦しみはさらに増えると
経済状況にしたっても
政治的な状況にしたっても
やっぱり鋭さがないということ
大変な問題なんです ですから
とにかくこの感情のポイントにまた戻りますけど
で 感情っていうのは この欲と一番わかりやすい
欲と怒りと 今 私がいつでも言ってる
このもうものすごく鈍感なとこですか
それは無知と言うんですね
その ３つ 一番大きな問題で
我々は精神的な病気 病人にしてしまっちゃうんですね
そこで我々大雑把な人間だから
欲なんか捨てなさいというのはちょっとどうかなと思ったりする
そう思うんだから 私はそれはもうとことんオーバーにして考えてくださいと
そうするとどうかなと見えてきます
で あの 時々人々が頭の中でいろんな欲があったりして
欲が生まれたら それは病気で物事を見えなくなっちゃう
何か好きになってしまったら
好きで好きでたまらない
それで常識が忘れちゃうんですね
忘れていろんな変なことをしてしまっちゃうんですね
いくらでもケースあるでしょうに
会社で普通のサラリーマンで
真面目に真剣に仕事をする人が
ある日突然女の人を襲ってしまったと
そういうケースいくらでもあるでしょうに
そこでみんな首をひねっちゃうんです
なんであんなに真面目な人があんなことをやりましたかと
お母さんとすごく仲良く遊んでいる小学生が
知らないうちに人を殺してるんですね
でお母さんもびっくり
学校の先生たちもびっくり
なんであの子は今まですごい真面目に言うことよく聞いてくれたのにと
であの どこかであったでしょう
学生がもう子供を何か残酷に子供を殺したケースが
神戸の方かな 何でしたっけ
その町が 全然誰もわからない
それはもう子供がやったことだと
どう見たっても あんなことは子供にできるわけないでしょうに
でも子供がやってしまったんですね
だから そのことをよく考えてみましょう
そのようなこと それでなんでそんなことをやったかというと
その子供は自分の心の中の感情の世界の中に
漫画の世界の中に 妄想の世界の中に入り込んじゃう
そればっかり考えている
そこで突然それを実行してみる
その実行している時は
その人には何もわからないんですね
だからお釈迦様がおっしゃるのは
怒りに征服されたならば
あるいは欲に征服されたならば
その時はもう目がないんだと
暗闇だとあるのは   アンダンタマン
ただホーティ その時はもうアンダン目が見えない
タマン暗闇だけですよと
それはその通りだと私は思います
例えばもうもう官僚の方々でもね
もうちゃんとした知識人でしょうに
すごい勉強できて しっかりした方々なんですけど
なんかある時で見ると
もうすごい もう決してやってはいけないことをやってしまっていると
そういうことだから やっぱりこの人間持ってる感情っていうのはものすごい危険なものなんですね
お釈迦様はこれはもう危険だと
明確に毒だと 敵だと 殺戮者だと
我々の心の中に毒があるんだと
敵がいるんだと 殺戮者がいるんだと
敵対者がいるんだと 自分を破滅にするんだと
それは貪瞋痴なんです
欲と怒りとこの鈍感というミスでしょうし
だから正直に頑張る なんかちょっと危ない言葉なんですね
だから正直かないかっていうことは問題じゃないんです
じゃあ逆に自分の気持ちに反対して行動すればどうですかね
自分が正直にはやりたくないんだけど
みんな言ってるんだからやるんだと
自分が正直にはこういうことをやりたくないんだけど
やっぱりもうやらなくやらなくてはいけないんだからやってますと
そういうことは じゃあそれだったらいいんですか？もし私の言葉から見れば
じゃあ正直になることは大変危ないんだ
じゃあ正直はやめましょうと
正直やめちゃって じゃあまあ自分の気持ちに反対のことをやってしまってやってみましょうと
それはいいんですか？といえば
そうするとどうなりますかね
1 日 2 日間は頑張れます
人が言うことは自分が全く認めたくない
全く認めたくないんだけど
一応 1 日目は言うことをやってあげる
2 日目も言うことをやってあげる
3 日目はもうブスブス文句言いながらやってあげる
4 日目はできないんです
すごいストレス溜まるんです
自分の素直な気持ちに全く反対のことをやるということは
これまたすごい苦しみなんです
すごい苦しみなんです
で  日本からいろいろ例をそういうことにはなんか出せたいんだけど
あまりわかりませんね
とにかく我々の正直な気持ちに全く反対
人が言う通りに言われる通りにやるっていうことは
またかえってストレス溜まる
それまた問題になる ですから
結局どっちでも問題ということなんです
正直に生きてみましょうということも問題であって
じゃあもう自分の素直な気持ちに
逆に反対に もうみんなから聞いて生活しましょうということも
それも危ないんですね
ストレス溜まってしまって
結局破壊したくなっちゃう
壊したくなっちゃう だから我慢できるということは
どこまでも我慢できるわけじゃないんです
いくらかは我慢できますけど
後でも もう何て言いますか
壊れてしまうんですね
爆発しちゃうんですね
我慢はそこまで それ以上はできないんだと
ということになります
だからどっちでも危ないんです
それでこの我々選ぶもう一つの道って何でしょうかね
やっぱり理解しなくちゃいけないんです
この貪り欲っていうのは
生まれたならば そこにあるのは自分には目がその瞬間でないんだと
智慧がないんだと だから精神的な病気だと
私たちはいろんなことで抑えられているんだから
病気にならないかもしれません
小学生みたいに このあまり抑えられてない状態だったら
一人のいる時間もあるし
妄想する時間いくらでもありますから
子供たちには 大人にはなかなかないんだから
社会の中でも生きてるんだから
朝会社に行ったら 会社のという社会でいなくちゃいけないし
それ終わったら飲み屋さんに行って
そこもまた社会であるし
家に戻ったら家族という社会がいるんだから
一人にはなれないんですね
子供たちにはもうかなり自分の世界っていうものはありますからね
だからいろいろ問題は作ったりする
大人も時々そういう問題作ったりする
まあ数で言えば大人の方が多いんですけど
子供は何か問題を作ったら
我々はもうなんかびっくりするんですけどね
まあそれだけのことで
子供より大人の方がね
まあ恐ろしいことをいっぱいやってますから
そういうことで このたとえわずかでも欲が生まれると
論理性からなくなって
論理性がなくなったと
合理性が消えたと 物事を見えなくなるんだと
例えば ダイエットしたいと思っている人が
自分の好物を目の前に持ってきたら
やっぱり食べたいと欲が生まれてくるんですね
やっぱり食べたいと思ったところで
この負けたところで 征服されたところで
欲にもう食べてしまうでしょうし
それでダイエットの今まで苦労した苦労は全部もう消えてしまっちゃうでしょうし
とにかく貪瞋痴に征服されると
その人はものすごい危ない
もう何やるかわからない
じゃあそれは極端的な例で
じゃあ我々生きているこの世の中っていうのは
どんな衝動で どんな感情で生きていますかというと
ただ単に貪瞋痴だけでしょうに
だから世の中で誰を見てもただのガキだけ
大人はいません 世の中でお釈迦様がおっしゃっているもう一つの道っていうのは
大人になりなさいということなんです
例えば アメリカのクリントンさんが自分がイラクを征服して
もうもうしたんだから
もう子供みたいに威張っているんですね
そこでイラクについてもう子供やることやってるんですね
喧嘩を売る 脅す 我々はくだらないよ
何言ったって脅しは脅しだから
人と喧嘩しようとするのは
するのは子供たちでしょうに
子供 どんどんそれ気をつけますけどね
そこでそちらにいるのはまた子供なんですね
精神的に じゃあ逆にイラクの人は何ですかと言えば
それまた馬鹿な子供なんですね
だから単なるもうガキ同士の行動であって
立派な大人の知識人の物事を考える人々の行動ではありません
じゃあ パレスチナとイラン
イスラエルの問題はどうですかね
どこにもそちらに成長は見えませんね
で 戦ってやろうと あいつの土地を奪って
イスラエル人が考える
我々ユダヤ民族はもうやっぱり成長しなくちゃいけないんだと
だから人のものを奪おうと
自分好きだからといってものを奪うということは
まあこれはもう成長している人はやることじゃないんですね
そこで誰が自分のものを取ったんだからといって
腹が立ってあいつを殺してやりますというのも
もうパレスチナ人も結局大人じゃないでしょうに
そちらにあるのは欲と怒りだけでしょうし
だから世の中で一人も人は成長していないんです
子供そのものなんです
それを何とかするのは
この第3番目の道で もう違う道なんですね
大人になりましょうと
で この例としてあまりぴったししませんだけど
こんなこと本当は言ってはいけないことで
私は外人だからね で 中国のね
あれ 大統領じゃないんですね
総理大臣 何ですか あの人
首相 うん 中国の首相来たでしょうし
なかなかうまくいかないんですね
この友好関係というか
この政府と政府間の仕事は署名していないんですね
共同なんとかという あれね
あちらどこの大人ですかね
僕に見えるのはもう小学生の子供二人の考え方と同じなんですね
俺がサインしませんよと
じゃあ俺もやりませんと
だからやっぱり 大人じゃないんですね
それでも本当に だから世界の状況っていうのは
だから悲しいんですね
私は第三者で言うならば
やっぱり日本は中国とものすごい仲良く
もうすごい友情関係を持って
お互いに組んで頑張っちゃえば
中国も助かるし 日本も助かるんですね
お互い幸せになるでしょうし
例えば日本の今の経済状況っていうのはそれほどうまくいかない
それで中国みたいな巨大なマーケットと一緒になれば
また経済はもうすごい勢いで回転するだろうと思いますけど
だから大人だったらそういうことを考えるんですけどね
子供は考えません ただ喧嘩する
嫌ですよとか それで終わっちゃうんです
だからそういう問題というのは
もうちょっと考えると
解決する方法はとても簡単にあるんですね
まあまあ これから本当に言ってはいけないことを言うんだけどね
あの 法律で禁じ 日本の法律で禁じられているんです
であの 例えば中国の首相が来ると言うと
日本側がその人はどんな人間かと
どんな性格を持っている人かと
どういう対策を持っている人かと
どこで生まれたんだろうと
何を好みは好みの食べ物は何ですかと
そういうのは前もって調べるのは普通ですけどね
そういうものを前もって調べた方が何者かとわかるでしょうね
それだったら この人と仲良くするためにはこうすればいいと
わかるでしょ それやってないみたい
だから私に見えるのは
この日本の側がすごい
できるだけ丁寧に謙虚で
もうすごい丁寧にしゃべりますけど
あの人はもう言いたい放題のことを言ってしまっちゃうんですね
僕は聞いたのは あの天皇陛下の晩餐会
晩餐会のお話だけちょっと聞いたんだけど
天皇陛下はすごくもう立派で
もう言葉選んできれいにもうお話はしたんだけど
それへの答えはもう全く逆
みんなちょっともう気持ち悪くなるというかね
あんまり言ってはいけないというかね
そういう場所ではね それぐらい大胆で
その人しゃべるんです
そこでその人はバカかというとそうでもないんです
なぜならば ソ連にしたっても
アメリカにしたっても
すごいうまくいってるんだから
世界の他の国々とうまくいってるんだから
だからそこら辺でもうやっぱりどこかで大人になってないところですごい損したんではないかなと
私なりの考え方だから
何も根拠はないんだけど
私は彼が問題は先に出しちゃったんですね
問題先に出した人はどうせ勝つんですからね
で 先に出されたならば
すぐこちらで答えを作らなくちゃいけないし
こちらはそういうことはしなかったしね
とにかくもうただ感情だけで互いにちょっとぶつかろうとしただけでね
彼が日本の前のね 戦争の時の問題と台湾の問題とか
それぐらい解決すればもう問題ないんだと言っていましたしね
来る前に ということは
彼の目的はもう日本とぎっしりと
もう 21 世紀向けてぎっしりとつなげて行動したいんだと
でもちょっとトラブル 2つあるんだと
それだけ だから それにもこちらであ
その 2つにはこういうことやと
向こう側から言われる前に
こちら先に言って もう中国人にも多大なもういろいろ損害を与えたんだと
我々はその痛み この恥ずかしさを現代人にまでずっと引きずっているんだと
ですから これからはそうならないようにと
というふうな言葉 こちら先に言った方が良かったんだけどね
ですから ただそれだけで
私はこの賠償金とか そんなものもとっくに解決しているんだからね
今の突飛したこの態度の問題だけでね
まあとにかくそれは余計なことだから
そこら辺でやめますけど
やっぱり我々はこの感情で生きてるんだから
事実を見ようとしない
話を聞いたところで この首相もかなり戦争のことでかなり悲しみにあった人なんですね
だからそこら辺ね ちょっと理解した方がうまく
国際的な関係をうまくいって
日本も幸せな幸福になるし
向こうも幸福になるし
社会も平和的になるし
今の社会でなぜ平和がないかというと
その人間は成長していない
怒りと欲 怒りと欲 その欲の中で高慢やら見栄やら
自分たちが偉いんだとか
誰にも負けませんとかね
そういうくだらない子供たちの考え方いっぱい持ってるでしょうに
例えばジハッドやらいろいろな言葉があって
このイスラムのという宗教をしている人々は
彼らの聖書で私たちは唯一の神様が信仰しているんだと
それ書いてるだけのことなんですけど
それからもう妄想するんですね
私たちだけ偉い 偉大なる神様を信仰しているんだから
私たちだけすごい正しいんだと
それで見栄が出てきて
世界中あちこちテロやら爆弾やら
そこで幸福ですかと アフガニスタンにしたっても
パキスタンにしたっても
もうパレスチナにしたっても
どこでもまあ殺戮 そういうわけで良くないんです
欲も良くないんです  欲があるんだから
もうこれぐらい危険になったんだから
それは良くないんだと
怒りも良くないんだと
危ないんだと理解しておかなくちゃいけないんです
貪瞋痴が生えたら もう餅なんです
もう餅といってももう病気なんですね
もう大人じゃないんです
この瞑想指導に来ると
私はよく言うことなんですけど
みんなに個人的には言いますけどね
この まあ大体集中力のポイントでよく言いますね
瞑想する場合は集中力は必要ですよと
集中力っていうのは不思議なものではないんだと
誰にでもあるんだと 集中力はわざわざ修行して育てなくても
もういくらでも集中力はあるんだと
それで例としていうのは
例えば子供がコンピューターゲームをやっている場合は
１時間でも２時間でもコンピューターゲームやってるんです
学校から帰りにゲームセンターに行く中学生なんかは
まあ塾なんかないんだったら
もう何時間でもそれやっちゃうんです
遊び始めちゃったら  12時であろうが１時であろうが関係なく遊んじゃうんですね
その時はまず気持ちいい
楽しい 疲れません 元気
一応 3つの原則があります
すごく楽しいと 疲れないと
それからもう 3番目はどれぐらい時間でもできるんだと
だから子供にもちゃんと集中力あります
子供にも何のことなく 1時間ぐらい集中しなさいと言ったらできるんです
一番小さい子供にしたっても
自分好きな漫画でもビデオで流してあげれば見ているんだから
じーっと体も動かせないんです
小さな子供に この幼稚園にも行く前の子供たちに
そのその好みのいろいろ漫画あるでしょうに
それを持ってきて もうミッキーマウスでもいいし
ドラえもんさんでもいいし
どっちでも見せちゃえば
じーっとこうやって見ているんですね
あの時はちっちゃな子供なんで
それイライラはない お腹が空いたとは言わない
泣いたりもしない それは集中力なんですね
正真正銘 それ別にわざわざ瞑想して育てるっていうことはどういうわけかと
もうとっくにあるんだから
そこで問題はそっちになるわけじゃなくて
このドラえもんを見ると
例えばもう 2歳ぐらいの子供は 30分でもじっとしているんだけど
他のことをやる場合はもう 1分以内でもう泣いたもんですね
イライライライライライラと
それなんですね ゲームセンターに入っちゃって
もう 2時間  3時間もゲームやってる子供たちに勉強しなさいと言っちゃったら
もうできない その時はもう眠いし
お腹が空くし 喉が渇くし
いろんな問題が出てくる
で 我々大人が子供にする
ものすごく怒るんですね
勉強しなさいと テレビ見るなと
強引に じゃあ大人ができてますかね
そういう大人が 全然できてないんですね
大人も同じく好きなことをやる場合は
もういくらでもやります
それで私はだいたい瞑想すると
まず立ちションしてもらうんですね
立ちションしてもらうのは
まあどうせみんなに嫌われるかもしれませんだけど
私はもう全部性格と人格ともう何から何までそれで読み取って
その人にどこまでできるかというプログラムを一応組んでおくんです
それには私にはちょっと 2分
3分は必要なんです で
まあちょっと 5 分間立ってくださいと
どうですか？と言ったら
グラグラするんだと 倒れそうになるんだと
なかなか難しいんだと
で という あの 何て言いますか
あの感想ですね そこで私ははい
わかりましたと それ以上は言いませんだけど
で そこは今はそういう関係じゃなくて
一般的な話だから 私の分析するんです
知ってしてあげます 分立ったところで体がグラグラしているということはどういうことですかね
まっさら嘘でしょう それで隣の奥さんと誰かの悪口を言う場合は
立ったままで３時間でもやってるでしょう
その時体もグラグラしないし
腰も痛くないし ある方がもう立った ５
分立ったところでもう眠くもなってしまったと
本当にその方は５分経ったら眠くなるんですかね
絶対そういうことはないし
それだったら危なくて
もうもうとっくに死んでるんです
例えばもう電車待ってる時でも
もう５分経っていると
もう眠くなって倒れちゃうともう命終わりますからね
そんなことは日常生活には全くないんです
あれは瞑想をやらせた時だけ生まれたことなんです
どういうことですかね
大人も幼稚園の子供とまるっきり同じということなんです
面白いことだったら集中力ある
他のことだったらまるっきりないんだと
だから どのように我々は大人と言いますかね
大人もいません この世の中で一人も
だから成長していない未熟な生命が誕生して
この肉体がどんどん大きくなって腐って死ぬ
中身はそのままで未熟なままで
そこで輪廻転生するでしょうに
そこでどこまで輪廻転生したっても
中身は未熟なままで そこは何とかしなさいというのはお釈迦様の言葉なんです
成長しなさい 大人になりなさいと
ですから 我々大人も テレビを見る場合は何時間でも見られる
仕事で疲れるんだ 疲れるんだという男の人々は
もう酒飲んで遊ぶ場合はもう何のことなく何時間でもやる
で 家に帰って奥さんが何かまあちょっとここら辺なんとかしてくださいと言ったら
私は疲れているんだからと行って
まあゴルフやらなんとかやら
もうどこかへ行って もう 1 日中遊んでくる
その時は疲れたとかなんとも言えませんね
そこにあるのは 我々は面白いことだったら集中力あると
面白くないんだったら集中力はなしと
それでまた子供に戻ってみましょう
子供の場合は集中力あるんだから
その子供には 1 日中ゲームばっかりやらせてあげましょうと
自分の子供はもう遊んでいる時だから
遊ぶ時は楽しいんだから
もう 24時間  1 日中ずっと遊ぶことだけにしておこうと思ったらどうなりますか？その子供の人生はそれで終わってしまっちゃうでしょう
だから 子供は嫌であろうとも勉強しなくちゃいけない
いくら嫌であろうとも
世の中のしきたり 常識を学ばなくちゃいけない
世の中の道徳を学ばなくちゃいけない
いくら好きだと思っても
遊ぶ時間はどんどん減らなくちゃいけない
そうすると その子供は成長してもう幸福になるでしょうし
その同じ原理なんですね
我々にとっても そこでこれ理解してください
我々は破滅するために
破滅する方には集中力があります
我々は不幸にする方向には集中力があります
例えば 酒に溺れることは簡単であって
酒をやめることは簡単ではない
タバコに依存することはいとも簡単であって
やめることはとても難しい
麻薬の中毒になるためには
もう一回だけ使えばいいんです
それでもう病みつきになるんです
やめることはものすごい難しいんです
世間話 ずっと喋ることは何時間でもできる
大事なことを喋るということは
もうなかなか難しい そういうことで
人間本来持っている集中力は人間を破壊する
だから違う方向へ持っていかなくちゃいけない
だからといって 嫌なことをやらせたんだからといって集中力は生まれてこない
例えば 子供はテレビばっかり見ていて勉強しないんだと思って
母親がテレビは全部もうもうまとめて箱に入れておいたんだと
それで子供は勉強しますかね？あるいはもう遊びに逃げちゃいますからと言って
部屋の中に入れて鍵をかけておく
じゃあ勉強しなさいと
部屋に鍵かけているんだからといって
子供は部屋の中で勉強するんですかね
嫌だったら嫌だから 逆に勉強はさらに嫌いになる
自分テレビ見たいのに
母親はテレビを箱に入れて
何て言いますか このテープも買っておいたならば
母親まで嫌になっちゃうんですね
鬼だと かえって逆に母親をぶん殴って殺すかもしれませんね
ですから 集中力作ろうという思いを持って
人に嫌なことをやらせることも良くないんです
そういうわけで 我々はいつでもこの違う道ということを言っているんですね
だから ヴィパッサナーの世界で歩くこと
座ること ごく普通にご飯食べること
そういうことに集中してみなさいと
嫌でもないし 別にやりにくいわけでもない
立ってみなさいと ただそれだけ
それで人間は正しい集中力が生まれて
人間に正しい集中力が生まれてくるんです
それ自由自在にそれ使えるようになるんですね
そういう人にとだけ 嫌なものは消えてしまう
特別に好きなものも消えてしまう
淡々とそのその仕事はできるようになってくるんですね
物事を見えてくるんですね
で  それで この貪瞋痴の感情で
生きている人間が まあ生きる道が
今生きている道が実は良くないと
危険だと 危ないだということは
まあ一応結論として まず答えとして言っておきたいんですね
もういいよ もう生ぬるいことは聞きたくない
例えば 人が欲がなければどうやって商売できますかとかね
その生ぬるい話聞きたくないんです
それも結局欲がいいということだからね
で 違う世界で考えてみましょう
まず人間というのは幸福で生きていきたい
それはもう別に悪いことじゃないんです
冬だったら窓を開けて寒さで震える必要はないんです
きちんと窓を閉めて カーテンがあるならばカーテンも閉めて
暖房があるならば暖房をつけても
それは一向に構いません
気に入っている相手がいるならば
結婚したっても それは全然構いません
寂しいだと思うならば
子供を作ったっても それは全然構いません
もっと美味しいご飯を食べようと思って
いくらかもっといい仕事をして金儲かったって
それは全然構いません
で 私たちいうのはそういうことではなくて
幸福になるためにはどうすればいいんですか？もっと具体的にも言えば
商売うまくいくためにどうすればいいんですかと
今一番肝心な問題ですから
そこで貪瞋痴で商売やってみてください
店やってみてください
儲かるそうと とことん儲かるそうと
全然お客さんが来ないんです
自分が儲かることだけ考えちゃうと全然うまくいかない
この経済システム なんで壊れて壊れてるかというと
ただ衝動は儲かることだけと
貪瞋痴だけだから 必ずもそちらにはもう大変な危険があるんですし
将来ではなくてずっとその危険に出会って苦しんでいるんですね
だから違う道っていうのは
例えば商売の場合は ある人間とある人間の間柄の関わりでしょうに
私は何かしらものは売っている
それで買う人がいる そこで商売成り立ちますから
買う人はそれは必要としている
そこで総合的に助かるということで商売成り立つんです
それを買ってあなたは助かる
それを売って私が助かる
ですから 商談の場合はどうやればお互いに助かりますかと
互いに幸福になるかと
相手の気持ちも考えなくちゃいけない
中国と日本の政府の間で話す場合も同じことなんです
日本側もどうすれば中国の方にもよろしいかと
日本の方にもどうすればよろしいかと
向こう側もどうすれば日本の方にもよろしくて
自分の方にもよろしいですかと
その接点を見つかればいいでしょうに
イスラエルの問題にしても
どうすればパレスチナ人が幸せになるかと
パレスチナ人もどうすればイスラエル人も安心して生活できるかと
その接点を見つかったところで
何のことはないでしょうに
問題が 欲でできません
そんなことは 欲で見ると
イスラエル人が自分の民族は成長することを考えている
パレスチナ人がとにかくもう自分の宗教で自分の民族が広げることを考えちゃう
自分の土地だと そうすると永久的に戦争だけ対立するだけで
なんでいろんな会社が倒産していきますかというと
このバランスを崩してるんですね
そのバランスが崩れたところでも問題なんです
だから世の中 貪瞋痴の代わりに
この共存のこと 互いに助かること
まずこのこれは幸せのためにやっているんだ
それを忘れるなと せっかく短い時間生きてるんだから
その短い時間 楽しく 幸せで
仲良く生きていればいいでしょうに
殺戮するなり 他人殺したっても
自分殺す その短い時間で起こることでしょうに
お嫁さんと喧嘩したっても
姑さんに喧嘩したっても
人生は短いでしょうに
その間で 10 年間姑さんと喧嘩してたんでしたと
あれほど馬鹿なことありますかね
10 年間喧嘩して苦しんで
そういうのを持ちな生き方でしょうに
だから我々はいつでも仏教で言うんです
人生は命は短いと いつ死ぬかわからないんだと
どんな瞬間でも死を落とせる可能性あるんだと
それは頭の中にじっと刷り込んで生活しましょうと
そちらに幸福の道があるんだと
自分の口でも  12歳ぐらいの子供たちを母親から奪ってしまって
奪われてしまって テロたちとして訓練させちゃって
だから子供ですから もうなんとか鉄砲はこうやって撃ちますよ
爆弾こうやってかけます
それだけなんで教えるの
で 子供だから誰も疑いませんだからね
そこで行って死ぬでしょうに
時々女の人なんかは自分の体に爆弾つけていて
もう大量の人を殺して自分も死ぬと
それは幸福な道ですかね
そんなことは 自爆と言うんですか？それ
何のためにあんなことをやるんですかね
そこであの いろんな宗教でそうやって死んだら
もう天国に行くんだと
あんまり だから合理的になりなさい
それは非合理的な考え方でしょうに
天国に行きますよと単純証拠はないんだから
聖戦という言葉あるでしょうに
そんな聖戦なんかあるわけないで
戦争だから 人殺すからことだから
そちら何が聖なるものですかね
なんで人間合理的にならないんですかね
たとえ犬でもぶん殴ること悪いことでしょうに
例えば犬 犬が自分を噛んだんだと
こいつをぶん殴ってやるぞと
それ自体も悪いことでしょうに
犬が噛んだんだから まあどうせ犬のことだからと許してあげるのは正しい道でしょうに
今日 自分の国の新聞で読みましたけど
この面白い記事がありまして
たくさん情報をまとめて書いてあったんだけど
この動物に対してなんですけど
まあこのヨーロッパの方でいろいろ法律がありまして
例えば アラビアであったかな
動物がもし人を襲ったならば
ちゃんと裁判を起こして
動物は死刑にするんだと
例たくさんあったんですね
ギリシア ローマでも アラビアの方でも
イギリスでもいろいろ裁判を起こすんだそうです
それでちゃんと弁護士も立てて
この動物はこういうこういうことをしましたから
そこで面白かったのは
何か人を襲ったなんとか動物をまず
あの 何て言いますか 捕まるでしょう
人間だったら あれ 逮捕する
動物を逮捕したんだそう
逮捕して捕まって 同じもう 3人人間がいる
部屋の中に入れて鍵かけたみたいです
で そこでちゃんと法律
人間の法律に従って裁判を起こして
まあ死刑と ということで
それはもう人間の ヨーロッパ人のね
もう頭の悪さというと
で かえって頭悪いんだけど
まあまあ もうどうせもう細菌文明発達したんだからね
しょうがないんだけどね
やっぱりまあ我々だったら動物をやったことだからね
もし犬が人を噛んで襲ったならば
犬を捕まってどこかにも檻にでも入れておけば
それで問題解決するし
で まあそれだけのそれでも弁護士まで立てて
人間の法律に従って裁判を起こしたっていう
結構長い記事でしたけどね
ですから この聖戦というものはあるわけじゃないんです
それで この人間っていうのは短い時間しか生きていません
その短い時間で 1 日でも損してはいけないんです
1 日でも悩んではいけないんです
1 日でも無駄にしてはいけないんです
人に対して怒ったら その怒りで誰がまず苦しめるんです
怒りは毒だと 殺戮者だと
敵だとお釈迦様おっしゃってるんだから
敵は自分の心にいるでしょうに
だからなんで敵を抱きしめて
お腹の中に入れておくんですかね
そろそろとやりたい放題でしょうに
敵が だから我々はたとえ 30 分でも何か出来事とあって
それに怒ってしまえばものすごい馬鹿な行動なんです
その人は人生損しているんです
幸福がないんです そこで心にその癖がついちゃうでしょうに
それから次から次へと怒るんですね
もう慣れちゃったんだから
悪口言ってみてください
最初は恥ずかしいんだけど
１回 ２回言っちゃったら
なんのことなく もう何でも言えるようになっちゃうんです
だから人っていうのは
そういう悪いことを一つ一回したら
一回はものすごく怖いんです
会社のお金でも 例えばたとえ千円でも横領するのはすごく怖いんです
それで一回やってしまえば
もう次にもやります それからもう取り返しつかないところまでやってしまうんです
で 人生が終わってしまう
怒りも同じなんです 一回怒ってみたら
もう何のことなく もう二回目も怒られる
で 三回目も怒られる どんどんもう慣れてくるんですね
そこで一生怒りの人間になってしまっちゃうんです
そこで自分の大事な幸福が消えちゃうんです
そういうわけで 貪瞋痴の世界には幸福な道がないんです
商売繁盛の道がないんです
欲だけで商売繁盛はできません
平安な家庭を作ることも
平安な世界を作ることも
自分で平安に生きることも
貪瞋痴では全く不可能なんです
で それは子供は生まれる時持っているんです
わがまま 怒りと それをもう叩き直して
新しい道を教えてあげなくちゃいけない
いわゆる調和は一番いいと
仲良くすることはもっといいんだと
楽な道よりは難しい道が一番いいんだと
子供は楽な道を選ぶでしょうに
人が喧嘩したらすぐ喧嘩する
日本であまり子供のことをあまり見ていないんだけど
自分の子だったら まあちょっとしたことでもう互いに喧嘩する
向こうは仏教の影響もありますから
誰もめげません この 例えば
なんていますか いじめられたと
で 泣きっぱなし そんなのはほとんど見えません
いじめられたら とにかく助ける
いてやっちゃうんです
だから 小さな子供の世界でもよく見えるんですね
ほんのちょっとのことで
もう互いにすごい喧嘩する
ある男の子がまあ随分私のまあよくもういつでも私のところに遊びに来たくて
時々来るんですけど いくらか頭のいい方でしたけど
でもものすごく怒るんです
ちょっとしたこと 怒って人を殴ったり蹴ったりする
で 親も他の親戚たちもこれだけはどうしようもないんですね
親にもすごい汚い言葉言ったりして怒られる
だから社会の中でそんなこと言ったら
みんなもう全然聞いてないふりをしてるんですね
でも結局心の中で悲しいと思いますけどね
私もその子はまあ本当はあの
ずっと自分勝手に生きて
まあ出家したいんだと
自分のところでずっと言ってるんだけど
僕はもちろん賛成しなかったんで
そういう性格だから まず性格直ることが第一っていうことで見ていて
ある日 私といろんなことを言いながら
偉そうなもう科学の話やらああだこうだとかね
まあ結構面白い話はするし
私言うこともよく聞くし
そこら辺は頭がいいんです
ちょっとしたことでも
一人のもう他の男の子と喧嘩しちゃったんですね
その子とも私と遊ぼうとしているんだから
こいつはもしかすると嫉妬してたかもしれませんしね
僕はさ この瞬間で言わなくちゃいけないんだと
いきなり聞いたのは あんたそれで自分が頭いいと思ってるんですかと
それであんた頭いいと思ってるんですかと
そんなことで人と喧嘩して
犬が噛んだんだから かえって逆に犬の足を噛むんだと
それはもう知恵のある頭の人やることじゃないんだと
何か言われたっても 何のことなく打ち消めていることは頭のいいということやと
言った途端 そこをもうパッと心に入って
それっきりではもう全然もう性格変わっちゃったんですけど
すごく性格が変わって
もうものすごい真面目で
で あまりにも真面目で
まあこれは私はちょっと困ってますけど
今は大人ですけど 今もう結構今はもうしっかりしたもう大人の子ですけど
やっぱり大人らしくちょっとないところもありますね
真面目すぎて まあそれちょっと直さなくてはいけないんだけど
なかなか会う機会がない
ですから この 怒りやら欲やら欲しいんだから取るんだっていうのも
あんまり大人らしくらしい生き方じゃないんです
その子供的な生き方は
我々は大きな銀行にしたっても
金融関係にしたっても
どんな栽培したっても同じことをやっているんだから
もう倒産するのはもう 3割
4割当たり前といったような感じで
もう当たり前なんです
だからもう一つの人生っていうのは全く違う生き方で
この共存すること 私が助けてあなたも助かるんだと
その生き方なんですね
そうすると世の中はものすごくうまくいくんです
私が人に対して怒ったら
その人も気持ち悪いし
私も気持ち悪いんですね
それで人が何か失敗したところで
まあまあいいんじゃないか
ということで許してあげれば
失敗した人もすごく助かる
ああ 立派な人やと この人言うことを聞かないといけないんだと
信頼してくれるでしょうに
そこで自分が怒らなかったこと
自分が自信がつくでしょうに
後で思い出したっても楽しいでしょうに
こんな失敗したっても
私はあの人に対して怒らなかったんだと
だから 別な人生っていうのは
貪瞋痴の感情の代わりに鋭さ
シャープネス 知恵 に基づいて生きていることなんです
そこでむさぼりと怒りの代わりに
ちょっと感情みたいなものを
感情は消せということは私は言っているわけじゃないんです
もっと素晴らしい感情
人間にあるんで 育てなくちゃいけない感情が
例えば生命はみんな兄弟だと
自分の子供だけ可愛いんじゃなくて
みんなまあ誰人間誰であろうと
母親の子供ではないかと
動物見たっても この動物のお母さんが一生懸命体舐めて舐めておっぱいあげて育てたんでしょうと
そう見るとなんとなくすごくもっと清らかな感情が生まれてくるんです
殺戮的な気持ちではなくて
そういう感情はいくら増やしてもいいんです
欲を求めて泣く歌でしょう
世の中にあるのは 恋 全部恋の歌やら失恋の歌しかないんだけど
泣くんですね せっかく歌を聴いて楽しもうと思ったら
こいつは泣いてるんだから
気持ち悪くてしょうがないんだけど
なんで慈しみをもう歌わないんですかね
僕は昔あったんで ウィーアーザワールドという歌がね
みんな集めて作った歌の
アフリカの色々国々を助けようと
あの歌を聞くと 私はなんとなく
あぁきれいな歌だな この人々
みんな素晴らしい歌手たちがまとめて
もう巨大なあれを作ったんだからね
みんな一行一行しか歌ってないし
ですから その時はやっぱり人のために
苦しんでいる人々のために歌ったんだから
ウィーアーザ ウィーアーザチルドレン
それを聞くと それは響くんですね
その通りやと それは逆に
なんであなたはあの人と言ってしまったと
それ歌ってどれほど気持ち悪いんですかね
別れの歌とかね ああいう風に
この それも怒りでしょうし
負けた気持ちでしょうし
あんなものは文学じゃないんです
芸術じゃないんです 人をダメにしちゃうんです
だから その代わりに慈しみというものあるでしょうに
だから慈しみを歌えば
平和を歌えば 小説やらもう踊りやら
いくらでも作ればいくらでも作られるんです
結局 ノーベル賞をもらうのはそういうものなんですね
ノーベル賞をもらっている小説なんか見てください
世の中に 全部何か人類に必要なものを言ってるでしょうに
残るものを言ってるでしょうに
だから他の文学なんか全部まとめてもうもう火付けたっても
別に損はしません 時間の無駄だけで
もし我々はこの貪瞋痴の代わりに怒りを仰ぐんじゃなくて
優しさを仰ぐこと 欲を仰ぐんじゃなくて
共存すること 互いに助け合うことを仰ぐんだというならば
もっと膨大な文学もできるんです
ものすごく美しく生きていられるんです
そういうことで まあ一応
別な生き方っていうのは作らなくちゃいけない
個人個人ででも作らなくちゃいけない
大人にならなくちゃいけない
この子供のまんまで死んでも
だから大人になると 大体はもう一般的な感情です
あまり気持ち悪いでしょうに
子供は可愛いんだけど
若者もまあそれなりにもう可愛いし
なんか大人になってくるともう全然可愛くないでしょうし
何でしょう 気持ち悪いでしょうね
これもう衰えてる体の中にもよじが入ってるんだから
合わないんですね 体と心が
小さい時はぴったし合うんです
心と体がもうバランスを整えているんです
体も子供で 心も子供で
ああ  OK と 可愛いと そこで体が年取っていると同時に
心も成長しているんだったらかわいらしさが消えません
そういうわけで 仏教の世界でこの悟った方々っていうのは
見ただけでみんなびっくりするんです
なぜかというと 立派な大人になっているんです
いるだけで いるだけでみんな落ち着く
頼りになる人の そういうストーリーはいくらでもあります
仏教の世界で このサーリプッタ尊者
智慧の第一人者というサーリプッタ尊者がなんで仏教に入ってしまったかというと
別に最初から苦しく勉強して勉強した上で仏教徒になったわけじゃないんです
これ ものすごい知識人でしたから
最も初めから ただ アッサジッという尊者が
もうお釈迦様の五重 五人比丘の一人で
もう出家して悟っただけで仏教もあまりわかりません
歩いているのを見て ただそれで
あ この人は違うんだと
やはり心と体が一緒なんです
こんなに落ち着き 不思議ですよと
それだけで喜んで で あなたの先生は何ですか？教えは何ですか？と聞いたんですね
そこでちょっと一行だけ聞いただけで
それで悟ってしまったんですけど
そこでこの仏教っていうのは
世界宗教にしたのはアショーカ大王
帝王ですね で それを歴史的な事実で史実です
そのアショーカ帝王がもう殺戮者で
インド中あっちこっち行って人を殺しちゃったんです
それで南の方を戦略するところで
あまりにも人々を殺されちゃったんです
その人々はものすごい頑固と立ち上がったんです
そこでこっちは力あったんだから
もう平気で殺しちゃったんです
そこで一体私は何のためにここまで人を殺して
この土地を取るんですか？と思って
自分が今までやったことで悩んで悩んで苦しんでいたところで
事実はどうかわかりませんだけど
ちっちゃな子供が出家している
子供一人が外で歩いて
まあ自分が自分の経典から見ていると見たんだと
見たら その子は子供なんですけど
しっかりして落ち着いて
何一つも焦りがなくて
徹底的に心を育ててきたちゃんとした人だから
歩くことを見て ああ この子はなんて言いますか
幸せだなと 平和だなと
このシャンティを得ているんだと
シャンティっていうのは平安
あの子は何か平安 安らぎを体得しているみたいだと
それで呼んだんです 呼んだところで子供は子供でしょうし
逆に出家しているんだから
インドは一応どんな宗教であろうか
宗教に関係なく どんな宗教の行者でも尊敬するんですね
ですから その王様が別に仏教とかなんとか知らなかったんだけど
とにかくどこに座ってもらえばいいかわからないんですね
子供だったらもう立ちなさいと言ったらいいですからね
言って じゃああなたは適当なところに座って座りなさいと言ったら
その子はもうこと言っての失礼ですけど
阿羅漢でしたからね 悟っていたんだから
じゃあ周り見たらもう他の誰もいないし
王様の手をつかまって手をつかまって玉座に座ったんだ
周り見たら これはすごく高いんだから
何のことなく手を捕まってもう平気で
その時でも自分がインドの帝王であるのに
全然気にしない そういう感じもない
ただまあ一人のおじいさんみたいな感じで捕まって
何のことなく堂々と座っていると
その時も王様に見えたのは
この子の心にあった この巨大な平安
それでこの教えを勉強しなくちゃいけないんだと
それから仏教を勉強して
世界で最初めの王様なんで
戦争をやめた王様が 私は今まで戦争してきたんだと
今日からはもう全くやりませんと
やめましたと 国を広げることは無意味ですよと
それよりは 人の心に平和をもたらすことは王の仕事やと
という仏教の世界にもう入り込んじゃって
彼のおかげで今世界中仏教は知られているんです
彼が初めていろんな各国に
ヨーロッパにも送りましたし
ちゃんと記録はありますから
スリランカにも スリランカが仏教になったのは
その人の息子が来たんだからな
ですから この心を落ち着いたならば素晴らしいんです
貪瞋痴の代わりに 逆のエネルギーを作れば
しっかりした明確な智慧が生まれてくるならば
そこに限りない幸福 限りない幸せがあるんです
一人二人でもその道を見つかるならば
大勢の人の人々の役に立つんですね
現代 我々生きている人々に言うのは
この激しく見栄を張って競争するんじゃなくて
やっぱり知恵を絞って落ち着いて生活してみればどうですかと
智慧が生まれてくるんですね
例えばもうもう経済状況が悪いんだ
悪いんだとかね 悪いんだからといって泣くんじゃなくて
うまくいくまで待ってるんですね
みんな いつうまくいくんですか？とか
こんなバカみたい口を開けて空を見て待っていたって
うまく自分が作った作った原因だから
自分で何とかしなくちゃいけないでしょうに
行動力がないんですね
チャレンジしませんね
で 怖さがあったりして
自信がなくなったりして
そういうことをやめちゃって
自分やることはしっかりやりますと
いや こんな嫌なことは嫌だとかね
好きなことは好きだとかね
そんなガキだと もうプロらしく生きていれば
大人らしく生きていればね
嫌だ 好きだ 嫌いだとかね
冗談じゃないんだと 恥ずかしいんだと
嫌だ好きじゃなくて 自分やることは自分のためになるか
人のためになるか ただそれだけでしょうに
ですから 正直かないかっていうことは問題ではないんです
自分の気持ちに素直に正直に生きていると
危なくてしょうがないし
だからといって嫌なことをしましょうと
それも危なくてしょうがない
どちらでも極端であって
そうじゃなくて これをやれば私は幸せですと
他人も幸せになるんだと
故にこういうことをしなくちゃいけないんだと
ただそれだけで生きていられると思いますけどね
そこでこの正直な言葉
もうちょっと言い残したことがございまして
で 育ててない人の正直さは危ないんです
大人になってない人の正直者はどうせ危ないんです
どうせ生まれつきあるのは貪瞋痴ですからね
ですから 自分が成長しなくちゃいけないんだと
成長することに正直になるんだと
貪瞋痴には負けませんと
欲を征服するんであって
欲が私を征服するようにはしませんと
そういう気持ちを作って
それに正直に生きていればいいんです
いわゆる悪いこと 自分が損すること
それから他人が損すること
いけないこと 殺されてもやりませんと
そこで頑固になればいいんです
何に頑固かというと 真理について頑固ですよ
正しい生き方 真理というのは
この神様が作った 作らなかったというのは
それは真理ではないんです
神様のために 国のために死んじゃったら天国に行くんだっていうのは
それは真理じゃないんです
あんなものはもう無知な人々のうわごとだけで何もないんです
真理っていうのは もう目に見えることなんです
悪いことはしてはいけませんと
来世があってもなくても
悪いことをしてはいけませんだから
怒ってはいけませんと
それのは来世があってもなくてもどうでもいいんです
威張ったら高慢があったら慢心になったら
自分も気持ち悪いし 他人にももうもう他人も嫌な気持ちになるんだと
そういうのは真理なんです
ですから 明確な真理に基いて
その真理を守るために頑固になる
正直になると そういう正直な生き方なんですね
そこでやがて素直になる
どんどん初めはちょっともうもともともう毒いっぱい持ってますからね
ちょっと苦しいんだけど
どんどん毒が消えると
まあ素直になってすごくリラックスして生きていられる
逆に言えば 初めは慈しみはないんです
他人のこと嫌いです 嫌いんだけど
他人のことを嫌うと自分も嫌われて自分の幸福が消えますから
涙流しながらでも慈しみを育てるんです
泣きながらでも お釈迦様は全くその言葉で言ってるんです
泣きながらでもいいんだから
いいことをしなさいと
悪いことをやめなさいと
泣きながらというのはすごくいい言葉なんです
なぜならば もともとやりたくない
もともとは殺したいんです
仕事をしてお金儲かるよりは
もうどこかであるものを奪った方が簡単です
ですから それは本来の気持ちで
ですから 泣きながらでも
嫌で嫌ででもいいことをしていきなさいと
それであなたはもう英雄であると
勇気ある人ですよと それでどんどんどんどん
例えば慈しみは最初からない
自分わがまま 自分本位で生きています
それで嫌なんですけど
やっぱり幸せでありますようにと思ったりする
嫌いな人のことも本当に嫌いだから殴りたいんだけど
やっぱりもうそれは良くないんだから
毒だから 幸福で幸せでありますようにと
納得はいかないんだけど
やると 正しい道だから
そこでどんどんどんどんどうなるかというと
みんな消えてしまうんです
嫌な人は消えてしまうんです
人がもう何か自分のものを欲しくて
欲しくてなんとかいうと
この人はとんでもない人
私のものを欲しくていろいろ企んでるんではない
その気持ちは出てこなくなっちゃうんですね
ああ この人 これ欲しがってるんだと
そういうふうに生まれてくるんですね
怒りではなくて ああ わかりました
あなたはこれ欲しいんだけど
本当はもう私にはこれしかないんだからね
困ったねとかね あげなくてもいいんです
あげられない場合は だからもうどうしましょうかと
そうすると相手方もまあやっぱりそれで終わっちゃうんですね
問題 もっと立派になったら
本当は私は私のためにこれ使ってますけど
あんたすごく美味しいでしょ
じゃああんた使ってもいいんですと
こういうふうにあげてしまうと
それはもっと立派になったら
とにかくすべての生命見ると
一緒に生活している気持ち
命ではないかということは感じるようになったところで
素直な生き方になるんです
そういう人々は微かな不幸も得られない
わずかにでも負けません
誰にでも それは本当に極端的に素晴らしく
絶対的に幸福になる道なんです
今の世の中やっている道ではないんです
今の世の中は否定したって意味がないし
肯定したって意味がないし
そういう違う道を見つからなくちゃいけないということでお話を終了させていただきます
どうもありがとうございます
はいはい どうぞ